[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream
179 I am Dr Brett Weinstein this is Dr
Heather heying and it is Wednesday which
has not been our usual day but we are uh
locked and loaded as they say it is the
solstice it is the summer solstice here
in the northern hemisphere the southern
the winter solstice in the southern
hemisphere I'm very glad to be in the
northern hemisphere at the moment
beginning of Summer mid-summers by some
mid-summer by some estimations but in
general now we think of this as the
beginning day of the summer
photo period begins to wane but it'll
just get warmer from here for a little
while winter is though coming the
forecast predicts Wayne
all right that was terrible it was
terrible it was terrible given the price
of admission it was all right I don't
know
so here we are 179 uh Prime
uh first half of a double Prime so two
episodes from now will be in a uh a twin
Prime sorry not a double Prime twin
Prime what is that
um and uh We're not gonna we're here
Wednesday because we're not gonna be
here next Saturday so you're gonna get a
little break from us you're not gonna be
here this Saturday uh yes and there will
be a couple of awesome guest episodes
being dropped this Saturday and next
Wednesday though tune in I don't know if
you want to say who it is probably not
no who they are
um but we think you will enjoy them
quite a lot quite a lot quite a lot uh
so
um here we are on Rumble if you are
watching that's where the chat is and uh
this will go out everywhere else we're
going to move all the rest of our stuff
to the end as we've been doing and just
move right into our ads and then then
get started talking about so there's
been some stuff even in the only three
days since we last saw you there's been
some stuff that has happened some stuff
has occurred yeah yeah yeah
um but let's get started with the ads
there are three sponsors right at the
top of the hour as always uh sponsors
whom we actually and truly vouch for and
you are I believe First yes our first
sponsor this week is fast growing trees
which is a brand new to us this month at
Darkhorse plants are life and a thriving
Garden is healing in so many ways fast
growing trees can help you get Lush
healthy trees growing on your land
quickly they've got everything from
fruit trees to shade trees to trees that
provide privacy and their fast reliable
shipping gets you whole healthy trees
fast
we had a crab apple tree delivered to us
this week from fast growing trees and we
are super impressed at this point that
was actually a few weeks ago yeah I
guess that I had to update that old
script yes all right just a mental model
update it's doing great I'll try to do
it on yeah it is doing great uh it
arrived fast was packed beautifully and
the uh tree inside is healthy and happy
we've gotten a pot for the moment uh to
move it around to see where it will fit
best in the landscape and it looks great
everywhere I put it clearly an excellent
tree yeah I'm looking forward to seeing
what it does when we get into the ground
fastgrowingtrees.com's plants experts
curate thousands of easy to grow plant
shrub and tree varieties for your unique
climate Meyer lemons to Evergreens and
everything in between whether it's your
first home or a seat or you have a
seasoned Garden
fastgrowingtrees.com has experts in the
field ready to support you and your
plants for years to come
fastgrowingtrees.com has your perfect
plants shrubs and trees with fast
growing trees fast and efficient
shipping you don't have to wait in line
or haul plants home in your vehicle you
order online and your plants arrive at
your door in just a few days that was
certainly our experience with the
crabapple tree that arrived before and
with fast growing trees 30-day alive and
Thrive guarantee you know everything
will look great fresh out of the box
join over one and a half million happy
fast growing tree customers go to
fastgrowingtrees.com Darkhorse now to
get 15 off your entire order that's 15
off your entire order at
fastgraintrees.com Darkhorse
our second sponsor this week is mind
Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in at
home ketamine therapy offering a
combination of scientifically robust
medicine with clinically guided support
for people looking to improve their
mental health and well-being if you were
someone you love is struggling with
mental health issues those issues May
Loom large in your life there is no
one-size-fits-all solution but you know
that you or your loved one needs
something that will help achieve a real
and Lasting breakthrough maybe it's time
for you to consider a guided ketamine
Therapy Program from mind Bloom mind
Bloom could be your next and most
successful chapter in improving your
mental health and well-being
mind Bloom connects patients to licensed
psychiatric clinicians to help them
achieve better outcomes at lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin you take mind Bloom's online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with a licensed clinician to determine
if mind Bloom is right for you if
approved you'll discuss your health
history and goals for mental health
treatment with your clinician to tailor
your mind Bloom regimen mind Bloom will
send you a kit in the mail complete with
medicine treatment materials and tips
for getting the most out of your
experience after only four sessions 89
percent of Mind Bloom clients reported
improvements in their symptoms of
depression and anxiety as one client
reports on their site quote mind Bloom
has enabled me to release the hold of
negative thought patterns in my life
mind Bloom has guided so many people
into a better chapter of mental health
and well-being right now mind Bloom is
offering our listeners 100 off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com Darkhorse and use
promo code Darkhorse at checkout go to
mindbloom.com starcourse promo code
Darkhorse for 100 off your first
succession program today once again
that's mindbloom
mindblom.com Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse
and our final sponsor this week is
Maddie's all-time favorite Sundays
Maddie is in fact here she's sleeping on
the floor behind us and her lips started
to twitch when I said her name I think
if she understands as much English as we
as we think she does she may start to
drool as I read the rest of this ad
Sundays we love it too because what dog
owner and dog lover doesn't love a
product that is great for their dog and
that their dog thinks is great too
Sundays makes dry dog food when they
approached us about being a sponsor we
were dubious Maddie our dog is a
labrador Labs will basically eat
anything what possible difference was
she going to show an interest between
her usual kibble a widely available
high-end brand and Sundaes well we were
wrong
Maddie loves the food that Sundays makes
seriously loves it in fact she's even
becoming just even becoming
she is even becoming Discerning and what
she wants to eat now used to be she
would eat absolutely anything now if we
run out of Sundays and give her her
previous high-end kibble instead she
just looks at it for a while then she
looks at us sadly sometimes she just
sits down doesn't eat she wants her
Sundays and guess what it is far better
for her than the standard burnt kibble
that comprises most dried dog food
Sundays is the first and only human
grade air dried dog food combining the
nutrition and taste of all natural human
grade foods with the ease of a zero prep
ready to eat formula Sundays is an
amazing way to feed your dog and in a
pinch
a person too
Sundays is easy for humans too no fridge
no prep no cleanup no gross wet dog food
smells Sundays is gently air dried and
ready to eat mostly for dogs no
artificial binders synthetic additives
or general garbage seriously look at the
label all of Sunday's ingredients are
easy to pronounce and healthy for dogs
to eat in a blind taste test Sundays
outperformed leading comparators 40 to
zero that sounds like a made-up number I
know but here's the thing when I have a
bowl of Maddie's previous food ready for
her she certainly is enthusiastic in
general again she's a lab when I have a
bowl of Sundaes ready for her it's a
whole different level of enthusiasm she
bounces and Spins and leaps in
anticipation do you want to make your
dog happy with her diet and keep her
healthy try Sundays we've got a special
deal for our listeners receive 35 off
your first order go to sundays4dogs.com
Darkhorse or use code Darkhorse at
checkout that's Sundays for dogs
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Dark Horse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your dog
laughs
still sleeping somehow
still sleeping after breakfast of
Sundays I expect it's good work if you
can get it yeah it is
okay so we're going to talk some today
about
um
about the recent
um Rogan Kennedy uh conversation and
some of the Fallout from that but first
I want to say a little bit about our
last live stream
and
um and the the upshot is
uh in terms of what what I want to talk
about I haven't told you this yet
because I want to I want to see how you
react in real time is that I'm I'm
disappointed in our audience
and here's here's why so usually I don't
look at comments and such but there was
enough of a certain kind of response
that I was made aware after this last
live stream so let me just back up and
say in this last live stream you showed
a clip of Rachel Maddow explaining on
behalf of MSNBC why they would not be
live streaming uh Trump's post
arraignment speech I said that I wasn't
convinced that this was egregious
journalistic malpractice many disagreed
with me that's fine you disagree with me
Zach disagrees with me that's totally
fine
what is disappointing is that many in
the comments Proclaim that why I was
disagreeing with you was because I've
got TDS Trump derangement syndrome
right so put it put aside the fact that
it's laughable right like you know if
you've been listening for a while if you
know
um if you've been watching us
um you can be certain that's not true
but um
but put that aside for the moment right
this is the same level of arguments the
same
um style and quality of argument as
people proclaiming the following things
if you disagree with the day of absence
the only possible reason is that you're
racist right uh the only reason to be
hesitant about covet vaccines is because
you don't think covet is a serious
disease
if you argue for single sex spaces for
domestic abuse shelters and prisons
you're really claiming that every person
who was trans identified as a criminal
right like each of these claims is wrong
right and so is the she said something I
don't like I'm going to mind read now
and attribute other things to her that
allow me to make broader claims that
actually have no basis in reality right
you're not a racist lots of us who are
hesitant about coveted vaccines actually
understand Kobe to be a very serious
disease and of course I don't know
anyone who thinks everyone who is trans
identified as a criminal right and and I
could go on and on and on with this kind
of list right
um
and we've talked a lot
um over the over three years on our live
stream and elsewhere about this
conflation of the position with
um the person hearing the position is
you know my interpretation of what else
it means about you and how you're a
really bad person right
and it's it's sloppy it's ridiculous and
it doesn't help right like part of what
we're trying to do here a big part of
what we're trying to do here is model
conversation including disagreement
wherein we can figure out where the
discriminant is sometimes we just
continue to disagree and sometimes we
realize that one or in some cases both
of us have some uh misinterpretations or
standing in a place that wasn't the best
place to stand uh and yet one of the
positions may be right maybe both
positions are wrong maybe both of them
have some truth you know there's lots of
lots of ways for disagreement to resolve
but attributing uh belief or intention
or motive to People based on a
disagreement is the opposite of useful
and it's a large part of what is going
on on the so-called Progressive left
that looks to us not at all Progressive
and that about which We complain a lot
and and point out the uh the problems
with that approach and so it was super
disappointing to see exactly that error
over and over and over again uh in in
response to our legitimate disagreement
last week yep or three days ago two
things one this is actually a very
useful so in general a uh strong bias
against mind reading yeah is uh the
correct way to keep your thinking uh
functional right right mind reading is
something most of us can't do we don't
understand what our minds are like and
there are a lot of reasons that people
might arrive somewhere different
differently than than you do I would say
a total prohibition is a mistake
obviously it is possible to theory of
mind is a kind of mind reading well yeah
right right you know it is one of our
superpowers as humans courts do this all
the time right they infer intent and it
changes the nature of the crime so it is
possible but one has to be very careful
about how you do it logically so it's a
it's a how to think question and it's
not a simple one
um the but in this case the idea that
you are suffering from TDS and that
motivated something about your
perspective on this is actually
something that
a I'm in a perfect position to know for
sure that that doesn't make any sense
because I hear all of our private
conversations and if you were suffering
from TDS I'd know it now whether they
believed me that that is not a fit is a
different question but again we can go
here and I think maybe we should but I
don't think it's the primary thing right
I know the primary thing is not like you
know what if I were right like what what
if you know what if I I did feel feel
this way it is still not you know about
about Trump right the fact that for
instance you know MSNBC was clearly
ideologically motivated in making the
decision they did clearly ideologically
motivated man I was much just said it
right they said he lies he's lied before
he's gonna lie again right
that does it does not follow that anyone
who sees that and says I'm not sure that
that is the egregious example of
journalistic malpractice you think it is
is similarly ideologically motivated
right that is an error right there so
whether or not I'm ideologically
motivated like as it turns out I'm not
in this case like by at least in this
regard but whether or not I am that
logical that that is a logical fallacy
there's a logical error to say they were
ideologically motivated they're for you
in saying they're not as wrong as the
people sitting next to you think they
are must be ideologically motivated it's
it's a just it's a logical fallacy it is
um the idea that one follows from the
other of course the you know the problem
that we have to deal with is sometimes
one can infer
intent and these people didn't do a
great job of it I will say I didn't
actually see that I'm sure it exists and
I just because my uh look was only
cursory what I saw was
um
what was the alternative to that it was
uh damn
um oh
the books that I saw complaining were
complaining about the fact that you did
not think it was a breach to not
broadcast Trump's remarks which wasn't
even the substance of what you said your
objection was based on the question of
whether or not they had an obligation to
cover it live versus cover it later and
while I disagree with you I do think
they had an obligation to cover it live
the point is that isn't even
uh consistent with the diagnosis that
was apparently leveled at you right so
and and I think that is so I didn't see
that but that you know again so a a
misread of a conversation for which you
could easily go back and replay the
conversation
um is unhelpful if what we're trying to
do is understand
um you know how to how to move through
this world with with Grace and
forgiveness and honesty and Truth
seeking yeah right and so you know
throwing uh throwing incorrect
accusations at people is clearly a tool
that is being used by lots and lots of
people and yeah I guess I was just I was
disappointed again to see it coming from
those who listened to us enough that
they were paying attention you know live
or you know in the immediate aftermath
of the of the uh
it's a live stream okay I want to
connect it to two things that I know are
going to come up later great
um some of which we have discussed
before
what you are
honing in on is a tendency to take a
landscape with some richness to it and
to turn it into a binary of black and
white right if you were on the wrong
side of this issue it is because X right
there's only one reason you might make
this argument which I have deemed to be
wrong and if you're making that argument
that I know
I know all the things about what
motivated it and so this a I'm going to
talk later about the tendency to make
things that are not binary binary and
the tendency to make things that are
binary continuous something we've talked
about a lot with regard to the sex and
gender landscape 100 and so my claim is
going to be a couple weeks ago we talked
about the fact that we are
struggling against the sophists central
trick which is because we are forced to
use language to hash out an underlying
truth that is not fundamentally
linguistic they can tangle the language
layer and we can't untangle it faster
than they tangle it but the point is
we're really arguing about something
that is true and deep and we are forced
into the superficial layer of words and
um and that is causing a problem so in
this case
I think our audience doesn't know that
they're doing it none of us do when we
engage in this but by taking something
that is complex and turning it into a
false binary right you force us into
this layer and the point is this layer
is not a productive place they're
hypothesizing about an internal
cognitive process that they can't know
anything about right and I mean it's
it's not just sort of neutral I'm like
oh that's not helpful it's it's
explicitly anti-helpful right like the
only reason you could disagree with the
only way that you could have arrived
disagreement here is because you have
trumped Arrangement syndrome yeah well
known I mean that I almost never will
there be a situation with you know in a
complex especially like political
landscape where the you know there's all
these people who believe one thing and
then the only way you could have arrived
at the opposite thing is through one
route yeah you know what are the chances
it's it's it's actually extraordinarily
unlikely
um that you have richness and diversity
of
um of root and of opinion on one side
and none on the other none at all so uh
you know that's it's it's easy to
demonize it's easy to mind read it's
easy to uh it's it's far easier and you
feel better I guess in the Moment by
saying I don't like but no not not
interested you know bad person uh stupid
person naive person has the syndrome has
the problem has the blindness therefore
I don't need to pay any attention and
certainly certainly there are places
where you've gotten so far and you've
you've listened to someone you've
listened to a position a lot you've done
a lot of research
um you've you know you've read the
primary literature whatever it is
whatever kind of situation it is and you
said you know what
at this point it's a high bar like I
don't I don't have to have to listen to
distractors on this point anymore
because I've already done all this
thinking the def you know the the burden
of proof is now on you well that's not
what the situation is but there are
certainly situations like that like you
know what I don't have to listen to
everyone who comes through the door like
you don't have to talk to everyone who
wants to talk to you and neither do I
right
um we get to make those choices
yeah um I also think this is a perfect
example if people are watching our
stream like we have a few haters who do
that mining for Stuff sure in general if
they're listening to us the point is
this is a place where you can afford to
just simply err on the side of a
generous interpretation of what might be
uh motivating somebody and in fact in
this case if you were to go back you'd
see that you were navigating you weren't
defending CNN but you were saying
MSNBC you were saying effectively I'm
not sure you have them dead to rights
journalistically because did they have
an obligation to broadcast it live which
is not that is inconsistent with the
position of you being ideologically
motivated and therefore siding with them
in not covering it they're two different
positions so anyway it's a good place to
test your own uh your own argument yep
okay
um
yeah and I guess I just one one more
thing and around this is that in the
middle of that conversation in in the
live stream from three days ago
I I said you know I don't like that we
feel compelled when we're talking when
we're introducing someone who appears to
be pilot politically for instance
different from us you know I don't agree
with everything he says right and we
talked about this with regard to Tucker
Carlson okay and uh I I will just I will
will remind everyone of that part of
that conversation which I think was very
fruitful that you know you shouldn't
expect to agree with 100 of what anyone
else in your sphere or outside of your
sphere says that would be
extraordinarily surprising unless you're
an idea look unless what you've done is
accepted all that you believe from
someone else and if other people are
doing that same thing then oh yeah you
know I everything I believe comes from
the RNC or the DNC or the who or some
other three-letter acronym that you
really shouldn't be trusting you do all
of your thinking for you well I would I
would say it slightly differently I
would say if you agree completely with
any complex set of conclusions
from somebody else then it is evidence
that what you were doing is not trying
to look for truth what you are doing is
trying to accomplish something a
coalition of people can agree to all
sign up for a slate of uh claims right
because it advances the ball but the
point is it isn't the same thing as them
believing those claims yeah I mean I
guess that's it feels it's important but
it feels like a slightly different point
that uh if you really can't find a point
of Distinction in your beliefs from
someone from someone else that is
evidence of the fact that you didn't
generate them yourself
why did someone else generate them for
you that's what you're talking about and
I think this is often where like you and
I tended to analysis at slightly
different levels like I tend to analysis
at the individual level and you are more
likely to tend to analysis the
population level
um with with regard to these sorts of
questions right and so I'm saying look
look inside of yourself if you feel like
if you're certain that you've got an
army of people who all think the same
and you're in lockstep
maybe you don't think the same at all
maybe you just don't think well what I'm
saying Nets out to
um
it goes without saying that I don't
necessarily agree with everything
ex-person Tucker Carlson says because
I'm actually trying to make sense of the
world and it would be natural to find
points of disagreement with literally
any person who had a similarly complex
view of the universe so at the point you
know so the fact that that needs to be
said is a symptom of the fact that a
large part of the conversation that
pretends to be about making sense of the
world isn't about any such thing it's
about politics it's about advancing a
ball right which is a necessary evil at
best yes
all right
um you wanted to uh begin the rest of
our time here today in front of the
camera by talking about an analysis uh
from Norman that was published yeah The
Marvelous Norman Fenton um do we have to
speak like that for the rest of the hour
not the entire hour no
um actually that was a pretty good
impression of Norman's family but yours
was to that last phrase was not bad
anyway I digress you can go back and
check the tape later you might want to
remind uh much of the audience so Norman
Fenton is a uh I don't remember what he
calls himself he's he's a mathematically
oriented uh
sleuth and academic British who has done
a lot of very interesting work on uh
substack he identifies himself as a
professor of risk professor of risk I
love that yeah yeah professor of risk he
might be the professor of risk but
anyway
um
Darkhorse uh fans will remember that he
was a guest and we talked extensively
about the various absurd covid claims
and the mathematical shenanigans that
had been used to generate them we also
talked about the absurdity of what has
happened to Wikipedia he in fact found
himself slandered as we have been
slandered and dug into it and found uh
you know a a a crawl space full of
interesting Critters underneath not the
crawl space you want to find yourself no
a crawl space full of creepy crawlies um
but anyway not enough airflow really
yeah yeah dank and not in a good way
yeah anyway is there a good dink
oh hell yeah the Dank memes
um anyway we'll talk about the Dank
memes later but for the moment uh let us
return to the issue of Norman Fenton and
an analysis which I only ran across this
week but which apparently goes back to
early May and it was on a topic that you
and I have covered where you and I have
been properly critical of a particular
um
structure in the uh testing regime for
vaccine safety and Effectiveness but he
revealed something that although there'd
been something nagging at me about it I
really just didn't spot it myself and
I'm a little embarrassed at that I feel
like I should have but uh wow does he do
a great job of pointing out the
following fact
yeah would you uh put up the um here we
have uh his peace uh
it's called the illusion of vaccine
efficacy Revisited so he's done a couple
of analyzes which he cites here at the
beginning of the piece the sent the
subtitle being how to make a placebo
look 95 effective and guarantee repeat
business right which is the degree to
which that title is actually just a
literal description without any
exaggeration of what he unearths here is
amazing he and his co-author who is
Martin Martin Neal yep
so the short version is this and I do
encourage you even if you don't want to
read about it there's a beautiful little
video statement video
hold on I think so but there's an eight
minute video that he does explaining the
analysis that is Crystal Clear uh that
um recommend that you go to but you're
going to explain it you're going to
explain the conclusion yeah I'm not
going to automatically robust but would
be difficult to do just in words I think
yeah I'm not having done the work
ourselves so here's the the error in the
protocol which you and I have focused on
a number of times the error in the
protocol is that people in a study that
compares a vaccinated population and an
unvaccinated population
there is a
um a shift anybody who comes down with
covid in the two-week period following
their inoculation is treated as
unvaccinated and the what I will by
protocol by yeah oh the vaccine isn't
effective right away and so we're gonna
pick us we're going to pick a period of
time uh during which yes you have
received the shot but we call you we
classify you as unvaccinated and that is
usually two weeks although sometimes is
something right here it's three so the
problem that you and I have focused on
which I think is absolutely egregious is
that there are
um immunological reasons that you might
even expect an inoculation to make you
more vulnerable to a disease like covet
and the short version of how that might
work let's say that you had had some
exposure either to a related coronavirus
or an earlier version of covet you had
an immunological response that was based
either in antibodies that respond to the
particular molecular motifs on the
surface of the of the virus or T cells
that respond to those same motifs okay
either way you've got a finite number of
detectors floating around in your system
and if you inject your system with
something that triggers the production
of proteins on the surface of the virus
then you will preoccupy a certain
fraction of your immunological cells
that can detect it right so it could be
that if you did that and so your immune
system is now reacting to vaccine
products it may miss an actual virus
that you encountered and that virus
which wouldn't have gotten through under
ordinary circumstances could get through
in that period that's at least plausible
so to say that you are effectively
unvaccinated until you've developed your
full immunity from the vaccine
is an absurdity because in some sense
what you really want to know is did this
injection make me less likely to get
coveted if it increases your likelihood
for a couple of weeks and then decreases
it for you know a couple of months
you're looking for the net impact on my
likelihood of Contracting the disease
you're not looking for after the thing
had finally done its work if it reduced
it and going to ignore everything else
yes so anyway that's an absurdity but
that's not what Fenton and Neil are
claiming here what they find is that
there is a
calling mathematical sleight of hand
built in here right where if you test
not the vaccine against a placebo
right so you have vaccinated and
unvaccinated but you test a placebo
against itself right and you use the
same protocol where you take anybody Who
develops the disease within the first
two weeks after they've been injected
with the placebo you treat them as
unvaccinated and you treat people who
come down with the disease after the two
weeks as vaccinated what happens is you
create a mathematical artifact in which
the vaccine looks highly effective if
you use the two-week cut off period it
looks to be almost or it looks to be
about 83 percent effective
so that turns out to be true
irrespective of the population size that
you use and irrespective of the
infectiousness of the disease in
question it's just a simple mathematical
artifact that comes from taking people
who did come down with the disease and
forcing them into the category
unvaccinated and then comparing the
unvaccinated to the vaccinated
yes I as I was concerned like this this
is an excellent piece and it's an
excellent short video and I do recommend
that people watch it I think I I'm
afraid that that was a confusing
explanation um there's no placebos being
taken there's no the argument is there
is no way to tell from from what was
actually done if the vaccine is better
than Placebo and in fact what we see is
uh when you run the numbers as if it was
a placebo you get exactly the same
supposed efficacy as you do when you see
when you actually look at what the
vaccine rates were and this is due to
this again this you know maybe
intentional maybe not sleight of hand
with regard to moving
um the first you know for the first two
weeks after you've been vaccinated if
you're in one of these um these trials
you are categorized if you come down
with coven those first two weeks you're
categorized as an unvaccinated coveted
case and that actually creates exactly
this graph that um that Zach is showing
here where early on it appears
that those who have been vaccinated have
a very low rate of covet in the
beginning and it appears that those who
are unvaccinated
um for like why would that change at all
in fact right like if you've had nothing
done to you why would your rates be
changing
um especially if you assume basically a
background rate of you know two percent
or one percent or five percent
infections uh you know which are all the
the numbers that he runs through
but what you see is actually those
numbers
um
those numbers approach one another the
the number of covid cases uh for
unvaccinated people and the number of
coveted cases for vaccinated people
approach one another very quickly
um and if you if you take out the
mathematical sleight of hand basically
all of the uh all of the evidence of
efficacy begins to fall apart well not
only that it as fent and Fenton does uh
use the same language I was using with
respect to Placebo so I don't think it
was confusing but
um
if you
um do if you generate the impression of
efficacy with this uh either error or
more likely trick
um if you do that you generate very high
efficacy at the beginning in fact again
if we have no functional vaccine
involved at all with a two-week uh cut
off you get 83 percent plus uh efficacy
and if you use a three-week cutoff as
was apparently done by the British you
get something above 90 yeah that's 100.
so but but what happens is that efficacy
drops off because it's an artifact of
what you got in the first phase you know
while people who were supposedly in this
period where they're developing immunity
differ radically because you keep
shoving the ones who got sick into the
unvaccinated group right so what that
means is you get the impression of a
very effective vaccine that
unfortunately requires regular boosting
right which I would point out as as a
Fenton and Neil imply
that is exactly what the companies that
produce these things would ideally want
the impression that what they've got is
a very good treatment or a medication
that requires uh constant boosting all
right that's that's almost ideal from
the perspective of uh of Pharma so
anyway I thought it was very interesting
for a number of reasons one
this is like the perfect level of
thought problem for a
a decent college class on statistics for
example right how do you generate the
impression how can statistics
artificially generate the impression of
a highly effective treatment for
something when there is no Effectiveness
because in fact what you've tested is a
placebo well this would be a very good
way to train people to realize that
actually
you can't just look at an efficacy
number like this and read anything
important into it because you have to
make sure that it wasn't just a simple
artifact of how you structured the the
experiment now the question though and
this is a question that has another
dimension is okay
it's subtle enough that you and I in
talking about this very particular flaw
didn't spot it okay yeah right so no and
I mean I think looking through the
article you
it took me a few times to carefully go
through what he is doing to kind of like
okay
I think I Intuit this now I think I I
get it now but I still don't like I you
know I did not offer to describe it
because I don't feel that I yet have it
exactly firmly so firmly within my grasp
but I can clearly describe it I'm not
sure that we have here yet so which is
why I'm encouraging people to watch the
video read the article
um but but you know so the fact that it
is not missed that is missed by people
even people who would criticize the
delay
um isn't surprising to me but it's also
very useful for those who would have us
believe in the efficacy of these
vaccines well but I'm I'm trying to get
to something past that
the fact it is a readily comprehensible
error it is also an error that one could
structure around if that was your intent
right you could simply start the clock
at the two-week Mark and you could throw
out anything that had happened
beforehand without shuttling anybody
right yeah and you could figure out how
effective these things were and if you
know in the case of a placebo you would
see no Effectiveness right you wouldn't
get the artifact from this initial
um you know shoving of people from One
category to the other but here's the
point
this error is
subtle at first and then glaring once
you see it what is the explanation for
this emerging
two years down the road after this
vaccination campaign as uh has been in
full force what is the explanation for
this not resulting in a massive Maya
culpa a refactoring of the claims of of
efficacy for the vaccines in other words
what has been Unearthed to you if we are
to believe that they didn't know what
they were doing and they just screwed
this up because statistics are you know
easy to mess up then the point is the
natural follow-on would be a whole lot
of well who did screw this up and how
did it get through the various kinds of
review and the regulators and all of
this and the absence of that is what
tells you something here is wildly amiss
what's more
in all of the debate about you know we
don't do science on The Joe Rogan
Experience because that's not a venue of
Science and you can hardly expect a
scientist to engage a non-scientist in
an unscientific venue of a comedian or
whatever the hell that discussion is the
question is well
okay
this is we're so not serious this is
having to be worked out by you know
professor of risk Norman Fenton on his
sub stack in order for it to reach
enough people to matter right via Dark
Horse and then who knows what else but
the point is we are being forced to do
the work in the places that do not seem
like the right place for the work
because the work is not being done in
the places that do seem like the right
place for the work and that haunts every
one of these discussions right why is it
happening on The Joe Rogan Experience
because it's not happening elsewhere
right
you know and and so anyway it's
the people who would tell us not to look
at them at the man behind the curtain
are doing the same I mean I we've talked
about this before but I use I used to
start out all of my programs when I when
we were professors when I was a
professor
uh by saying you know what what is
science let's talk that through and what
does a scientist look like what do
scientists have and you know I'd have a
slide be like oh scientist definitely
has an advanced degree and probably
wears a lab coat and has a lot of fancy
glassware expensive instrumentation and
definitely some big grants hopefully
from the NSF or NIH depending on you
know what kind of research they're doing
and like no no no no no no you don't
need any of that right in fact
increasingly the more of those things
you have maybe the more likely that
you're actually not doing any science at
all these proxies for science that are
useful for those who don't think
scientifically who don't think of
themselves as scientists go like oh God
I'm supposed to follow the sign I'm
supposed to trust the science we live in
a post-religion world I'm a secularist I
don't know what to believe I know I'm
supposed to trust the science I'm going
to look for the guy in a lab coat over
there now does he have a degree cool is
he uh tenured somewhere awesome does he
have a lot of Grants terrific okay I'm
gonna listen to him
not the way science works just not the
way it works so all you've done is
replace one Authority for another and
are you surprised that the new Authority
is lying to you well you're not because
you don't yet understand the new
Authority is lying to you but they but
they are patently and they have been for
three years no you know maybe it's
closer to 30. but like that's what
they're doing so the proxies are not
sufficient that's not what science is
those people aren't scientists and the
ones who are like oh I am a student
scientist and I'm not going to go on a
rogue and like well you already went on
Rogan dude like what were you doing then
if you weren't talking about science
so I think it is certainly true that
that is not science
but the thing that is hard to convey is
the degree we all have an impression of
science because we all know that we are
standing on a huge accumulated bed of
wisdom produced by this method that has
made us into the modern creatures that
we are and has provided tremendous
benefits and insights and we feel
enlightened right
that is what happens when science is
done properly but it is the flip side of
another coin science is so capable
and because of the things that make it
capable it is always also extremely
fragile right it is so easy to do
something that is scientific looking in
every regard screw it up in one place
and come up with the inverse of the
right answer because for lots of reasons
because science is done on the honor
System because it assumes that what
you're trying to do is be right in the
long run rather than get tenure or
something like that yeah it seems you're
seeking truth rather than
self-addulation right and so the point
is our system is a complete mess it
happens that at this moment actually you
are more likely to encounter a reliable
scientific claim on Joe Rogan than you
are in you know the land Building the
Lancet for example right that does not
mean that every claim made on Joe Rogan
is right but it just means that the
people who are trying to be right May
well be sitting in those chairs on
Rogan's podcast and if you're inside of
the academy it may be that there's an
enforced Orthodoxy that you're you know
you're claiming that sex isn't binary or
you're claiming that these vaccines are
vaccines and that they're safe and
effective because if you do anything
else it's catastrophic for your career
so how you can't do science under
science cannot be done under those
circumstances medicine as
um you know broadly a subset of like
applied science yep you know
in a world where your medical
practitioners insist on referring uh to
women about to give birth as birthing
people
yeah that's not going to be a place
where you can go to and expect to hear
hard truths it's not gonna like you
already know you're being lied to and I
don't know whose feelings exactly
they're protecting I mean I kind of do
but why is why are anyone's feelings
being protected over the seeking of
truth and the revealing of reality
sometimes it's going to be ugly often
it's not but regardless that's what we
are trying to do yep
all right so I think uh we have
let me just I don't know if what I said
about uh Fenton and Neil's work was
clear or not but in the interest of just
uh wrapping it up
if you take people who come down with
the disease
during this period in which they might
be developing full immunity if they'd
actually been injected with something
that would do that and you shove them
into the unvaccinated category because
they are not they have not yet reached
that end point what you are doing is
defining them as unvaccinated right they
are unvaccinated by definition you're
taking sick people people who landed in
the sick category and most of the people
in the study never end up in the sick
category you're taking people who ended
up in the sick category at the beginning
of the test period and you are making
them unvaccinated by definition so but
you know just to be be clear you're not
doing that because they're sick
you're doing that because it's the first
two weeks after vaccination well you're
not you're not moving people between
categories because they are sick I'm not
even sure what that distinction means
because you are the reason that they got
moved was that they became sick
so you are moving them because they're
sick now why you're motivated to do that
everyone is considered unvaccinated for
the first two weeks or three weeks
depending after vaccination
well true but you're talking about
people who you did vaccinate right and
then you are shoving them into the other
category because they became sick so
this is a semantic Nuance but the point
is it is they're having gotten sick that
caused you to graft them on to the
unvaccinated category which is cheating
right so
anyway it is it is an egregious breach
of the scientific Integrity here and if
it's accidental then it should have
resulted in a whole lot of backpedaling
and searching for how such an error
could have got so far into the
literature right and the fact right and
re-analysis which then should have us
you know we should be having
Congressional hearings about these
vaccines and what effect they actually
did have both positive and negative and
the point is
we see uh no no Instinct in that
direction among the people responsible
yeah sure
um I think the point you're trying to
make or to real reveal that Norman made
is that it is
assumed I think anyone who looks at
those statistics before you see the
error assumes okay if they say two weeks
down the road is when you count as
vaccinated that that's the point at
which they start the clock to start the
clock instead they've artificially
extended the clock by an extra two weeks
for you to be able to get sick if you're
unvaccinated and shortened that by two
weeks for if you are vaccinated so it's
just a four you know if you are taking
data over eight weeks it's actually
um 12 weeks and four weeks back or ten
and
4 respective or is 10 and 6 respectively
and so it's just two different clocks
all right that's good yeah that's good
okay
next phase
um
the question about
um the failure the egregious failure
that is revealed by Norman Fenton leads
to another set of questions
so many people will have seen uh in um
Barry Weiss's publication the Free Press
Free Press finay Prasad had a response
to RFK Juniors claims which was
published
um yeah show it here yeah let's show it
and it's uh called what RFK uh gets
right and when RFK Jr gets right and
what he gets wrong I think the subtitle
is even more interesting Dr vinay Prasad
fact checks the presidential candidate
on vaccines regulatory capture and more
yep now
this is interesting and of course
um
vinay is true to form
quite good in some places and
surprisingly uh immune to seeing the
same sorts of Shenanigans in other
places and I do not know I truly think
uh Renee seems like a good guy but I
can't figure out why the pattern is what
it is it is conspicuously off
um in particular is that do you want to
show so uh vinay goes through this fact
check of RFK Jr and then of course
Alex marinos well before we before we go
to Alex Moreno so he specifically takes
on um Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine
and um and then also childhood vaccines
um so before you talk about what Alex
marinos had to say about uh vinay
prasad's fact check as published in the
Free Press the link so he has two links
to Ivermectin that he proposes as
evidence that Ivermectin doesn't work
here's the first one Zach if you would
show this the first link is to the usfda
article from a couple years ago why you
should not use Ivermectin to treat or
prevent covid-19 with a picture of
that's right a horse like literally he's
linking to an FDA article from before
most of the trials were even done in
fact the article says like trials are
ongoing so hey this isn't The Smoking
Gun Prasad would have you believe it to
be B it's using that same old crazy PR
campaign about its horse medicine right
like I cannot believe they're still
doing this but that Prasad actually
links to it the Free Press lets him do
it like I would like to see the supposed
evidence and of course marinos will you
know destroy it as he has done over and
over again but you know seriously you
link to an outdated FDA article
um with uh aspersions to horse medicine
in it as your evidence that Ivermectin
doesn't work not very strong evidence
doesn't look like fact checking to me
yeah and you know there was a massive
campaign to cause the public to see
Ivermectin as especially Veterinary in
nature right horse paced right that was
what was done to Ivermectin now the
question is why
now let's show uh Alex's tweet thread
yeah so Alex fact checks Prasad
and of course dismantles this argument
um
where Prasad says on with respect to
Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine uh RFK
Jr got it wrong and if you'll I cannot
read at this distance
um you want to you want to read the
first several tweets
um you don't have to read the quote you
want me to yeah can you but you you have
to start at the beginning I think Zack
you want to scroll back up
uh so here marinas has a as an image
from the relevant part of the Prasad
article in the Free Press every magnetic
hydroxychloric we got it wrong with
regard to Kennedy getting it wrong
reminder writes marinos uh vinay Prasad
MD mph asserts that ultimately
Ivermectin doesn't treat coven 19. this
despite the fact that the meta-analysis
he bases this on when updated and
despite absurdly tight filters is just
one RCT randomized control trial away
from showing a statistically significant
mortality benefit
let's scroll down dad wants me to read a
few more he started making these claims
in a post on his sub stack comparing
Ivermectin and masks and claiming that
since both do not clear the
statistically significant barrier and
the meta-analyzes of his choice
Ivermectin should be considered a failed
therapy
of course the Ivermectin meta-analysis
he chose is measuring mortality benefit
when Ivermectin is given his earlier
late treatment in the case of masks
they're measuring infections when used
as prophylaxis why didn't his chosen
meta-analysis on Ivermectin also
investigate ivermectinus prophylaxis you
want to keep going yep I think one more
even stranger writes marinos if we look
at the pre-registration of the marcolino
meta-analysis which Dr Prasad relies on
for his analysis it promised to look at
prophylactic studies too
so what happened with that result why
didn't vinay compare like for like okay
keep going one more well this
meta-analysis
registered that they would analyze
prophylaxis and treatment for treatment
they list 16 endpoints prophylaxis
literally vanished no mention in the
paper a registered treatment endpoints
they only presented one out of 16
mortality
all right so I want to sort through
what's going on here
first off
you have a process whereby
actually let's start somewhere different
what I want to know is for the folks who
find themselves yes acknowledging that
uh lab leak appears to be the likely
explanation for covid and yes the
vaccines did not turn out to be
effective at controlling the disease and
yes there's a large adverse event signal
that we didn't know about it first right
but Ivermectin doesn't work right that
series the question is why are you
Landing there right for one thing
you have just seen a series of
Revelations that make quite plain that
the system
does not function to test the safety and
effectiveness of
Therapeutics in a way that is reliable
so to then point to the same systems
product and say well with respect to
Ivermectin we know you know yes it was
promising at the beginning but then it
turned out that it didn't work well
here's the thought experiment I want
people to run yep take yourself back to
your mindset before covet right what did
you think before covet what did you
think about Pharma what we called Big
Pharma did you think big Pharma could be
trusted with your health or did you
think it needed to be carefully watched
because the profit motive made it
unreliable okay so in such a mindset
your pre-covered mindset ask yourself
the question so posed that there were
literally hundreds of billions of
dollars to be made on some new platform
Therapeutics that would be impossible to
deploy if there was an existing drug
that was both safe and effective at
treating covet in that case do you
expect Pharma to allow that other
therapeutic to prevent the accumulation
of hundreds of billions of dollars and
to allow this drug especially a cheap
generic generic drug out of patent you
know delivered around the world
unusually safe like safer than lots of
drugs in your medicine cabinet do you
expect Pharma to forgo the hundreds of
billions of dollars or do you expect
them to in some way attempt to create
the impression that this other drug
doesn't work right so in that thought
experiment I think you would come up
with the idea that oh geez I guess
I would imagine Pharma might take some
action to try to
um
to derail the impression of
Effectiveness especially in light of the
eua which requires that there not be a
therapeutic so it really is a binary in
this case either there is a therapeutic
in which case you don't get to deploy
mRNA vaccines for example
um or there isn't a therapeutic in which
case you do and there are lots of
benefits there not just the money that
was made in covid but you've got a
platform that isn't yet ready for prime
time that you can lots of people are
into mRNA yeah you can speed it through
uh the regulatory apparatus you can get
people widely accepting of this new
technology which they might have been
rightly skeptical of if it had been
presented to them correctly
so you've got a huge incentive for
Pharma if something like Ivermectin or
hydroxychloroquine Works to
um
to find reasons to think that it doesn't
or can't be used right okay so you've
got these two
compounds hydroxychloroquine and
Ivermectin
and you might say well the prediction of
the Pharma corruption hypothesis is that
if you look into the work that does tell
us that hydroxychloroquine and
Ivermectin don't work that you will find
Shenanigans right and if you find
Shenanigans then maybe the idea is
Pharma is driving this and if you don't
find Shenanigans then maybe they don't
work right this is actually a place
where uh I will gently fact check RFK
Junior also he said during the um the
Rogan podcast I think you just made a
mistake and I'm sure he's very good
about correcting stuff when you talk to
him about it
um
but he said that in the case of
ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine very
high toxic high doses were given enough
to be toxic that's certainly true for
hydroxychloroquine the problem is it
doesn't even work that way for
Ivermectin because it's so it's such a
uh non-toxic drug that giving a dose
that would produce a toxic consequence
is very difficult so that did not happen
with Ivermectin it did happen with
hydroxychloroquine they gave absurdly
high doses so okay that's one kind of
shenanigans that you see but what Alex
is pointing out here in his thread is
and it's far from the only one but it is
it is the shenanigans that you see when
you look into the Ivermectin trials
so you've got hit by his description
you've got uh Prasad
uh defaulting to a meta-analysis in
which a Ivermectin is dealt with as a
treatment right and the end point that
is chosen is uh death is Ivermectin
preventing death now death is a very
important thing to prevent right but the
problem with using that as an end point
for the study is that covid isn't
sufficiently lethal to get a large
sample so you can say this was a large
randomized controlled trial but the
number of people who reach a relevant
endpoint and therefore allow you to see
this is extremely low and so I want to
give a an analogy so people can see this
Crystal Clear
pose
that we tested the efficacy of Neosporin
and that we use the endpoint of death
right so what we do is we've taken let's
do a large study because heck we want to
really know obviously have Neosporin on
new Cuts new Cuts right so we get a
million people and we put half of them
in the control group and we put half of
them in the treatment group do we let
them cut themselves or oh no they
they're going to go out into the world
and we're going to I don't know
encourage them to engage in Reckless
Behavior in which they may receive a
laceration at any moment excellent and
excellencies
good stuff man so okay so they go out
into the world and they start getting
Cuts as people do and
um as soon as they get a cut they're
forced to call in and we rush them to
the hospital and if they're in the
treatment group we apply Neosporin to
their cut and if they are not in the
treatment group we well the people doing
the applying don't know but the
researchers in the back room who know
who's in what group hand out it's
Vaseline versus there you go clean it
all you know you wash it with soap and
water and then you either put some
vaseliness and Neosporin on okay okay
and at the end of the study here's what
we're going to find out
Neosporin is not effective
at preventing death after no it's not
effective we're just going to say we're
going to stop that's not effective yeah
that's what we've done in order to
determine if it's effective is we have
looked at its consequence for death
right right right and but we've
determined it is not effective and
therefore we are going to mock anybody
who says oh no it is effective right so
yeah that is a ridiculous shenanigan
okay in the case of covet it's slightly
less ridiculous because people do die of
it but the point is most people do not
die of this and therefore by choosing
that end point
um you have already suggested what
you're hoping to find Now worse they so
in order to prevent Shenanigans like
this you're supposed to register your
endpoints ahead of time so that you
cannot in the end go back and Shuffle
what you did and cherry pick a result
here and there right especially I mean
they I mean they almost hit 20 right
like they had 16 possible engines and
they provide one and I don't know maybe
it was my I haven't gone back and looked
maybe it was medical and so they're
p-value they were shooting for was 0.01
but it was 0.05 and they had 16 original
endpoints they reported one like that
looks very very dicey right there
because the chances that one of them
would not be effective was really close
to 100 right so to put this in in Lay
terms yeah if you said I want to know if
Ivermectin is going to work and here are
16 different measures that we're gonna
make we're going to take all the data
we're going to look at what it is and
we'll probably get a mixture right
um and then the point is you only report
one oh which one did you report
um you know was it the you know the days
till recovery right right no you chose
death which therefore makes the bar
incredibly High and the stuff everyone
who's not paying close attention or
hasn't thought about these things like
well I care about whether or not I died
don't I why would you why would you tell
them they shouldn't care about death
right but now it's about the bar height
it's a it's a it's about the bar height
and
it is about when you suggest 16 things
that you're going to measure in order to
find out once and for all whether
Ivermectin works and then you report one
and you've chosen the one with the high
bar and you didn't report the other so
we can't even look at it and figure out
well why didn't you report it right so
you know the point is this smells a lot
like [__] right and the thing is
it's not alone every time you look into
the stuff on which these claims of
ivermectin's failure to be effective are
based you find similar [__] you will
find a discussion in my recent talk with
Dr Corey about the extremely arbitrary
cutoff in the dosage protocol in the
together trial and the active six trial
where covid a disease that
disproportionately affects people who
are obese where instead of continuing to
increase the dose with body weight as
you're supposed to with Ivermectin they
put an arbitrary weight cut off so
the point is
go back to your pre-covered mindset
right Pharma cannot be trusted right
Pharma cannot be trusted and if there's
hundreds of billions of dollars at stake
and a couple of generic drugs might get
in the way you might expect Pharma to do
what it can to uh
um to slander those drugs to mock people
who uh have used them to good effect
right you would expect those Shenanigans
what should you do when you expect those
Shenanigans you should look into the
studies and the meta-analyzes that say
that the things don't work and see if
you find [__] and it's like oh it's
amazing how much [__] they actually
jammed into those things right it's like
inconceivable how much [__] there is
in the Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine
trials deadly [__] in the
hydroxychloroquine trials yep and so
anyway that's the question and so
the real upshot here is not Pharma it's
not
um the
regulatory apparatus I think that what
we have found is
um an educational scandal
all of these folks who think yeah okay
maybe it was lab leak and uh all right
maybe the vaccines weren't effective and
it turns out they're way less safe than
we thought but Ivermectin doesn't work
right
where did these people go to college
because I think that place needs to be
shut down that place did not teach these
people how logic works it didn't teach
them how to pursue a correct answer and
Frank some of them were allowed to
handle glassware
and run experiments on expensive
machines well no doubt but nonetheless
that gave them what they needed I mean
okay all right maybe we can't shut down
this faulty institution but I would
think actually a lot of these people who
appear not to be able to follow through
to a logical conclusion once they've
seen a pattern like this might have a
cause of action against the institution
whatever it might be and so
um I I don't know maybe maybe they
should seek Justice yeah maybe they
should maybe they should
um okay
um
okay so I want to talk about one more
thing can I add one more thing on that
topic before we go
um we're not going yet I have some
things to talk about before we move on
here here's the analogy that I think
represents where these people are
falling out and how absurd it is imagine
that you were
um you had a corporation and you wanted
to build a big corporate campus and you
hired a engineering firm and uh the
engineering firm gave you designs and
you built an office tower
and you built a parking garage and a
bridge to allow people to drive in over
the beautiful Majestic Ravine at the
edge of your campus
and one day your office tower falls down
and
when one looks into the matter one finds
it actually at an engineering level it
was not designed to be robust and it
looks like the plans were full of
nonsense and uh rainbows maybe unicorns
who knows what it is somehow the
engineering firm is guilty of gross
negligence when it comes to the office
tower it just was not designed to
withhold withstand the forces on it and
when you look into the parking garage it
turns out it's also not capable of
withstanding designed and built by the
same people same time oh my goodness
yeah not good they're going to have to
tear that thing down it can't even be
retrofitted but it's got cars in it
Brett though we're using it they'll pull
the cars out somehow but we are using it
we are using it but the bridge
everybody's still you know as they're uh
going into uh help tear down the parking
garage they're driving in over the
bridge the assumption is well the bridge
was built by experts right they did all
the engineering here they're you know
the blueprints and the question is well
why now that you've seen the office
tower fall down and you've discovered
that the parking garage is badly
designed do you still trust the goddamn
Bridge right why is anybody trusting A
system that failed them so much across
the board on these other topics when it
comes to repurposed drugs and that I
think is just it's a strange mystery
yeah right it is
it's it's just odd it's conspicuous it's
conspicuous and I guess actually
um
the other link that Prasad gives in his
piece published in the Free Press um
back to checking RFK uh this
conversation with Rogan
this last week the other Iber missed the
first Ivermectin link goes to an FDA
article that has a picture of a horse
proudly displayed on the front of it and
the other one goes to a popular article
in Washington Post that itself links to
other popular articles like the Wall
Street Journal and it's just it's just a
bunch of claims like this doesn't work
okay but that's not how science works
that's not how evidence works it's not
um this journalist over here said X oh I
can quote that journalist over there
saying Axwell to Washington Post said X
like this is the opposite of how science
is supposed to work and frankly it's
embarrassing it should be embarrassing
for someone claiming to be fact checking
someone claiming to be acting as a
medical doctor as a scientist to be fact
checking medical and scientific claims
to be using the Washington Post and an
old article on the FDA as evidence of
the fact check it's not and you know he
knows that he knows that so
um I want to go to another piece of this
article
um
where
so I also encourage everyone to listen
to the RFK conversation with Rogan three
hours
um it's it's remarkable and the other
piece of it that uh Prasad takes on
which you know with which he strenuously
disagrees it's not just the repurposed
drugs I've ever worked in
hydroxychloroquine it's childhood
vaccine safety right so Prasad focuses
on RFK Junior's contention that
childhood MMR and DTaP vaccines are
responsible for the rise in autism
I don't know
if you had said that to me
two years ago five years ago 10 years
ago 20 years ago and people did I would
have said no stop it I'm not not going
there not listening not interested
well one has to begin to be interested
in looking and going there at this point
I don't want to
I haven't gone there yet but I don't
know I am not simply going to dismiss it
out of hand as I have in the past and
frankly
um again the links that Prasad puts up
as is evidence against the claims that
Kennedy makes are puff pieces one is to
the Mayo Clinic oh Mayo Clinic they're
doing medicine they must know but it's a
puff piece it just asserts the safety of
childhood vaccines but it once again
doesn't actually provide any evidence so
assertions are not evidence assertions
are not science assertions are not the
basis on which we should be deciding
what it is to inject into our children
it's not it's not how it's supposed to
work and again I don't want to be here
right
I don't know
however there is another claim that
Kennedy makes uh on on Rogan's podcast
that I do have some knowledge about uh
which is one that uh there hasn't been
nearly as much focus on which is that he
says and I don't have the direct quote I
wasn't sure exactly where it was in
there I don't have the direct quote
something to the effect of none of the
vaccines currently in the childhood
vaccination schedule in the U.S have
been tested against placebo
put aside for the moment whether it's
whether or not it's true we'll get there
what does it mean what does it mean if
it is to what does the claim mean uh
basically all new drugs including
vaccines are supposedly safety tested as
we are all should be well familiar with
at this point and everyone imagined that
that was the case until you know
even before coven right like obviously
the drugs have been safety tested that's
what the FDA is for that's what all of
the you know that's what the CDC is for
that's like what all of these
organizations are for I guess the CDC
decides what's on the schedule and the
FDA is doing the is doing the safety
testing
specifically phase three clinical trials
which is part of the vaccine safety
system in the U.S
have at least two groups those who
receive the new treatment to the new
drug the treatment and those who did not
the control treatment versus control
many of these phase three clinical
trials have more than those two groups
they may have multiple treatments they
may even have multiple controls but the
control group
the control group
should be a group
that does not know that they have not
received the drug
but who is otherwise on drugged
at base right like that's what the
control group should be they don't know
and best if it's you know double triple
quadruple blind where like no one knows
whether or not you as a as a participant
in a trial have or have not received the
treatment right no one knows
they should in short receive a placebo
right in the case of an injection
it should be a saline injection it
should be you know if if the treatment
is an injection you're going to have to
receive an injection as part of the
control group else you know that you
have not received
I would just add one thing
um
at some point we can get back to
placebos and the placebo effect but it
is important irrespective of what you
think of the placebo effect it is
important to have the elements of the
interaction that are short of the
molecule or whatever being tested right
so they will even go to the extent in
the case of surgical treatments of
giving a sham surgery so that if the
anesthetic for example is having some
effect that that is neutralized because
both groups have gotten it so
neutralizing the effect of the
interaction with the system is important
having nothing to do actually with what
people commonly understand the placebo
effect to be about Placebo is the
neutralization of those other
effects right now
that throws a bit of a wrench in here
and I think we're not going to go there
but we will probably end up coming back
to it another time the idea of
anesthetic being part of a of a control
it's not
than a placebo because anesthetic does
have an effect right so if you have if
it's an injection if it's an injectable
drug that is being tested in a phase
three clinical trial you have the
injection with all of its ingredients in
in the in the treatment group and you
should have a saline injection in the
other with none of the ingredients of
the thing in the control group so
testing vaccines against Placebo or none
of the things that are in the treatment
group rather testing vaccines against
Placebo is critical RFK claims that
vaccines currently the childhood vaccine
schedule have not been tested against
placebo
if true how could that possibly be true
right what else would they test new
childhood vaccines against like how how
is it how could it possibly be true that
the things that almost all of us are
injecting into our babies and our
children throughout their early lives
not been tested against not having the
drug at all
well it is true and the the question of
what constitutes a placebo does begin to
get us into a little bit of um of
complicated Waters here but here's just
three examples I haven't
I have not independently verified this
is true for every single childhood
currently recommended on the childhood
vaccine schedule by the CDC but I have
seen very careful analyzes and I just
haven't gone into the actual
um the pharmaceutical reports that are
the inserts with the vaccines for all of
them but for some of them I have so here
are just three examples DTaP which is
the diphtheria tetanus and acellular
pertussis vaccine
has never been tested against Placebo
what has been tested against is the
older dtp vaccine
and the older dtp vaccine which was
generated in the 1930s was never subject
to uh
to clinical trials at all dtp is in fact
known to be dangerous and so we all know
all we all we know rather all we know is
that if the clinical trials for DTaP
were otherwise done well even if
everything else was according to
protocol and according to good
scientific thinking all we know if they
if gtap comes out looking good in those
clinical trials is that it is not as
dangerous as the dtp vaccine was
we have no evidence the DTaP itself is
safe relative to not getting any vaccine
at all okay similarly that's an
egregious abuse of the concept of
placebo right so and I I have reason to
believe that this is the case for every
single one of the vaccines currently on
the childhood vaccine schedule this is
apart okay so here's the other two that
I specifically looked into and there are
of course many more as we've talked
about in the last couple of weeks when
we were talking about the book where
there is no doctor and the recent
changes to the childhood vaccine
schedule both in the U.S and worldwide
HIV which is hemophilus influenzae type
B was never tested against Placebo it
was tested against depending on the
trial there were lots of different
trials lots of different vaccines
because
because as Kennedy also reports in that
Rogan conversation uh basically end of
the Reagan years uh Farmers Pharma gets
a release on immunity from things and so
we start to get the market starts to get
flooded with vaccines okay so there's a
lot of HIV vaccines out there a lot of
different trials it's never tested
against Placebo in any one of them it's
tested against a different HIV vaccine
it's tasted against DTaP which again was
tested against dtp which wasn't tested
against anything at all it's tested
against other vaccines yet or in some
cases tested against literally all of
those at once
no Placebo test at all okay so how do we
know that they're safe
one more
pneumococcal disease also never test
against Placebo prevnar 13 which is the
newest version of the vaccine uh for
pneumococcal disease was tested against
prevnar
the original version okay what was
proven our tested against oh that was a
control group
um that received an experimental
meningococcal vaccine
the original prevnar the original
pneumococcal disease vaccine was tested
against another experimental vaccine
and now the new prevnar vaccine is
tested against that first one which was
tested against a different experimental
vaccine none of them ever tested against
Placebo in none of these cases do we
actually know
if they are safe relative to just not
getting an injection at all with with
these drugs safe relative to getting an
injection with saline that is what we
need to have happen so
I don't know I don't know
what is true about childhood vaccine
safety I don't I don't know what I do
know is that the vaccines that we're
giving our children have not been tested
in the way that everyone if they thought
about it would assume they had been
tested and that that is shocking so
um
I
come up with a principle for how to
think about such things because what you
know what you've just described yeah is
a situation in which a
signal of harm could easily be masked by
such a protocol
does that mean that there is a signal
form
we don't know so
the principle is
there are many things in a category and
the category is I don't know if it does
harm but I can tell you that it isn't
safe right and you and I have drawn this
distinction between these two things
before when you if you drive home drunk
and you make it right was harm done no
was it safe no so safe does not mean
harmless right safe means that there was
no risk so in this case we don't know in
the case of those three vaccines
whether or not there is a signal of harm
that is being masked but there's a place
that it could easily be masked and
therefore we can't say it's absent how
is it possible that so-called safety
testing is being done that has no chance
of revealing whether or not that harm is
being done well even worse how is that
possible so again go back to your
pre-covered mindset
um
Pharma can't be trusted because it has a
perverse incentive okay
let's imagine that
are there bad studies yes it happens all
the time does Pharma create bad studies
yes there are books actually on how
Pharma creates bad studies
is it possible for Pharma to get a
dangerous drug or vaccine authorized uh
yeah
um it it happens or approved is probably
the better term yes so what happens if
Pharma manages to get a vaccine approved
in spite of having a massive risk and
then
they start using that as their Placebo
to test other things right something
that does harm right that you can then
use as a placebo against other things to
mask harm that they might do so if you
imagine that Pharma like a an immune
deficiency syndrome
is carving a hole in the regulatory
apparatus so that it can put more drugs
on the market and make profit this would
be a great way to do it is to redefine
what Placebo means and then use that
mechanism to get dangerous stuff used as
placebos which then causes the drugs in
question not to seem to have a safety
signal there's one of these childhood
vaccines and I don't remember which one
at the moment uh apologize that one of
the clinical trials did compare
and this may seem analogous to your
surgery example right did compare the
treatment the full vaccine to the
control group which was everything in
the vaccine except the actual
um the actual I don't remember but the
actual pathogen yep
um
so
that might seem like and you know you
could sort of squint at that and go like
well okay so we're just testing whether
or not it's the actual uh you know virus
um in the medicine that's doing the harm
however
what you've done there is you've
injected babies
and young children literally with the
slew of contaminants that are adjuvants
that are there in order to prompt the
immune system to have a reaction and not
given them the actual medicine
so that's not only is that not a placebo
that's criminal well it is
you can come up sophistry can be used to
generate a justification for that right
for anything apparently were you
actually interested in safety in order
to get to that justification you would
have had to test all of those things
against an actual Placebo before you
then used them
to test the the important ingredient but
nonetheless this is another not all of
them one-on-one either like that but
also the combination of the cocktail
minus the actual potential efficacious
agent which is the you know the virus
the attenuated virus or whatever it is
um and the whole thing as well like you
have to do all of those all of those
comparisons in order to know whether or
not what you've got to say but this is
another sleight of hand right because as
with the case of
um you know narrowly testing the uh the
vaccines against
um an end point right
when what you really want to know is is
there an all-cause mortality benefit to
this vaccine yes right I want to know
what the net impact of injecting
somebody with this is right but instead
what they're going to do is they're
going to focus on the my new show and
the real point is look
I don't care if it makes me safer from
covid if I'm likely to die sooner from
some slew of other inputs right so I
want to know what the net impact is and
this is the same thing where the idea is
actually I don't really care if the
molecule in question the the antigen
that they're using or the attenuated
virus or whatever it is that they're
using what I want to know is the net
impact of the injection right and so
anyway there's a lot of sleight of hand
as you would imagine if Pharma had
completely captured the entire sector
right yes why why are they being allowed
to so-called safety test vaccines in
this way right well how is that how
how is that being tolerated and how is
it that people who pointed out
will a hundred percent be painted with
the anti-vaxx brush no this is pro
science this is not anti-vaxx this is
pro science you people who are claiming
to do safety testing by comparing known
toxins to new potential toxins
that's anti-science that's what you're
doing you are demonstrating a complete
disrespect for truth reality science and
Humanity like end of story like that's
what they're doing right
um and the implication of it uh
it again let's
um rerun the tape let's go back to our
pre-covered mindset okay and then move
forward with one change
the um those with the instinct to
silence critics right the people who
accused us of being
anti-vaxxers or conspiracy theorists or
any of the other Slanders that were used
to shut down discussion let's just
imagine that that had worked right so we
got through covid
no Rogan right Malone doesn't have a a
venue Corey doesn't have a venue
McCullough doesn't have a venue right
you and I are silent John Campbell
thrown off YouTube you know so the point
is the mainstream narrative
carries the day right
and we arrive here in 2023 with that
having been the only change well
what is it that people would currently
believe right they would currently
believe that the vaccines had been safe
and effective that they had actually
controlled the pandemic right they would
have believed all of these things they
would continue to believe that they
would be they would continue to believe
that this had been a zoonotic uh
outbreak and therefore that the money
that we have spent uh on gain of
function research has been too little
not too much
um because what we really need to do is
accelerate that work so the next time it
doesn't get out ahead of us right if you
silence those voices
then in 2023 you are living a totally
upside down garbage narrative designed
to make Pharma the hero of the uh of the
pandemic and many people are many people
are well many people are but my my point
is the current discussion we are having
right about you know geez were all of
the things that RFK Jr said on Joe Rogan
true right you know well look you're
dealing with one of the few venues in
which truth managed to get out and it
put Pharma back on its heels so you know
is perfection the standard that you're
looking for there no what you're looking
for is the net effect of us being able
to have these discussions
has been very positive we'd probably be
much better off if the sensorious thing
had been shut down itself and we had
been allowed to speak freely about this
and doctors had been encouraged to voice
their concerns right we so we're living
in you know a halfway position where we
did manage to have discussions we
weren't supposed to have and so
civilization is way better off than it
would be because it has Insight in a lot
of these things but yet it still
believes total nonsense on repurposed
drugs for some reason still hasn't
figured out uh the relationship between
um vaccines and Escape mutants right
still hasn't figured out the IG
igg4 issue and the suppressed immunity
that we're seeing right so it has a long
way to go but we could be a lot worse
off if we had simply if if the people
who now want to shut down these
discussions
you know on uh Joe Rogan's program had
succeeded two years ago
I would like to propose that what they
are engaged in those people who would
like to shut down the conversations the
people not just at the so-called public
health organizations like the CDC and
The Who and not just at this supposedly
you know scientific Grant granting
institutions like the NIH and niid and
NSF and all the academic institutions
and all the journalistic outfits
um who you know had you know coveted
reporters that you know reliably got
everything wrong that they're engaged in
a follow-the-science circle jerk and
that um that's all they're ever going to
be capable of doing at this point is
patting each other on the back or Worse
maybe it's more fun for them
uh but it's not revealing anything
outside of their little bubble that's
there's there's they're stuck in their
space and they are
slugging their ears and screaming
whenever anything comes in that looks in
any way
dangerous to the narrative I think a lot
of people who think of themselves in
who don't think that they are fully
Orthodox right who don't think that
they're just following along
um sort of have given themselves an
allotment for how much heterodoxy they
can take
right like there's like oh well I
already like okay I'm on the wrong side
of this and like my former you know my
former liberal this and you know I I I
I'm anti-woke and I talk about it and so
I just don't want to make us make a fuss
over here I'm not gonna look because I
can't afford to lose more people or more
credibility or more whatever oh and
sometimes the excuse is well I'm not a
scientist so I can't assess it and why
do why should I believe you when I can
just believe all these other people who
I know are lying to me about other all
these other things but I'm just going to
trust them on this one even though the
stakes are really a lot higher so you
know what everyone needs to get over
this everyone needs to get over this oh
I've already been heterodox in one part
of my life today I did that I took that
heterodox pill and so like I'm done for
now I'm gonna go back and like just go
mainstream for the rest of the day
because it allows me to enjoy my
appetizers well someone will like [__]
you like stop this you're you're
seriously destroying people's lives and
on the basis that you think you're
following some science that isn't
science it doesn't exist the science on
which we are basing so many of our
decisions doesn't turn out to exist at
all it's incredible yeah so this is this
is my concern about the middle ground
scramble it's exactly what this is if
you have if you have a budget for
heterodoxy rather than yeah hey I don't
know how much has been compromised but
every time I look under one of these
rocks I see the creepy crawlies it's
like well put it back put the rug back
right the thing to do is to become
agnostic not to double down on the part
that you're not ready to look at and so
you know that is what I'm getting at
like how is it that you've seen Vinnie
vinay how is it that you've seen what
you've seen about the vaccines and you
apparently haven't looked deeply into
the question of ivermectin right if you
did look you would find Shenanigans of
the same sort that accompanied the
vaccine so there's no the amount of
heterodoxy it's not that heterodoxy is
good but the point is in an era of you
know
pure corporate [__] heterodoxy is
the way to see with Clarity right in an
era in which the system actually
functioned it wouldn't be
doesn't mean there's no heterodoxy there
will always be you know people who see
beyond what we collectively understand
but somebody is
uh actively deranging us and seeing past
their nonsenses is key and um you know
and I guess you know we haven't talked
about the middle ground scramble in many
months but the middle ground scramble is
the obstacle to fixing the problem it
seems like it's halfway to the solution
it is actually the thing that will be
used to prevent the actual solution yep
that's right
I think I've done ranting for today
you're done ranching for today yeah yeah
I've I've I'm at my limit and I'm just
going to go on and enjoy my appetizers
now
all right well I didn't know there were
appetizers but uh I thought you oh yes
um well um we're gonna have light
appetizers yeah
drink the sunshine there it is okay well
there we go
um
we are going to be away for uh nine ten
days depending on how many days are in
June I don't remember
um we're gonna come back on Saturday
July 1st it'll be our next live stream
and then we'll have a few in Rapid
succession and then
um away again a little bit and then
we're going to start actually live
streaming on Wednesdays at this time 11
30 a.m Pacific um beginning a little bit
into June um for the foreseeable future
because our producer is going to be up
with us oh July yes our producer who is
there going
let's go
um yes that that that will be true and
we will have a website at some point too
where we can put that those scheduled
things
um in the meantime there are going to be
two great guest episodes coming out
before we live stream with you again
um be on the lookout for that consider
uh subscribing to our channel on Rumble
and then you'll hear about these two
great episodes that are coming out
before we see you next as a live stream
and
um other places that you can find us I
of course write on Natural Selections uh
natural selections.substack.com Brett
has Twitter subscriptions open now we've
got uh
darkhorsestore.org where there are lots
of great great things including lie to a
tyrant and Pfizer where the
breakthroughs never stop and uh just uh
plain old Dark Horse branded merchandise
and at some point I don't know if it's
up yet actually but some people were
asking for little Dark Horse pins by
which you could kind of just communicate
to other people hey I I'm a dark horse
person and I think that those are up if
not they they will be up soon
um and so that's uh that's at
darkhorsestore.org
run and The Print Shop is run and the
store is managed by a lovely couple in
Louisville Kentucky right here in the
United States our book of course is
available everywhere hunter-gatherers
guide the 21st century and
um we had a great conversation on our
patreon on my patreon on
um this last Sunday
two days ago it's been a lot these last
few days
um and we encourage you to join us
either of our patreons and the Discord
server there is fantastic you can have
honest conversations about all manner of
things and do things like happy hour and
karaoke as well
and consider checking out our wonderful
sponsors this week if any of those
Services apply to you excuse me fast
growing trees if you need some plants
mind Bloom if you
um think that you or a loved one might
benefit from guided Academia therapy and
Sundays if you have a dog that you love
which if you have a dog I presume
assume her links are in the show notes
is always we are supported by you our
audience we appreciate you very much and
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
foreign
[Music]